y lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
ver un resumen de todo lo que ha pasado
en la tierra desde que se creó empecemos
con la formación de la tierra y del sol
se cree que hace mucho tiempo había una
supernova muy cerca de la galaxia
esta es una fotografía del residuo de
una supernova la supernova de kepler la
supernova de esta fotografía existió
aproximadamente hace 400 años en 1604 la
estrella explotó y se pudo observar por
cuatro semanas porque era el objeto más
brillante en el cielo fue observada por
kepler y otras personas entonces esta
imagen es lo que queda de esa supernova
que al explotar generó una especie de
onda de choque y ha viajado por
cuatrocientos años ha de estar viajando
a velocidades muy muy rápidas incluso a
velocidades relativistas
es decir cercanas a la velocidad de la
luz pero imaginemos que cuando se generó
la onda de choque de la supernova
supongamos que aquí hay una nube de
moléculas puede ser una nube gaseosa
cuando se originó la onda de choque la
gravedad no era tan densa como para
tomar estas moléculas y crear un sistema
solar pero cuando la onda de choque pasó
por esta nube comprimió todo el gas
todas estas moléculas y eso les dio la
densidad suficiente para formar un
sistema solar eso es lo que se cree que
ocurrió y la razón por la que se cree
que todo empezó con una supernova es
porque la única manera conocida en la
que se pueden formar elementos muy
pesados es con el calor de una supernova
y al parecer el uranio se formó
aproximadamente al mismo tiempo que se
formó la tierra
es decir hace aproximadamente 4.5 mil
millones de años así que al parecer el
uranio tiene la misma edad que el
sistema solar por lo que seguramente se
formó al mismo tiempo y fue por una
supernova entonces la onda de choque de
una supernova pasó a través de esta
parte del universo con lo que el gas se
condensó y se formaron muchas otras
cosas si avanzamos a algunos millones de
años después el gas formó algo como esto
porque logró alcanzar una temperatura
densidad y presión crítica en el centro
para que ocurriera una ignición y así
pudiera iniciar la fusión por ejemplo la
fusión entre el hidrógeno y el helio así
que este es nuestro sol en sus inicios y
alrededor del sol tenemos todos estos
gases partículas y moléculas con una
velocidad angular
suficiente como para orbitar alrededor
del sol incluso también tienen un poco
de presión porque podemos ver esto como
una nube de gas muy grande en el que las
moléculas chocan entre ellas pero lo más
importante es su velocidad angular así
que durante los siguientes millones de
años las moléculas partículas y gases
chocaban lentamente y se agrupaban
incluso las partículas pequeñas tienen
gravedad y lentamente se convierten en
rocas y asteroides que les podemos
llamar planetesimales son como las
semillas de planetas o protoplanetas y
al tener una cierta gravedad otras cosas
son atraídas lentamente hacia ellos y
así se van agrupando pero todo esto no
fue un proceso tan fácil imaginemos que
aquí se forma a un planeta si mal y aquí
se forma otro pero en lugar de que se
junten tranquilamente como viajaban
ciudades muy rápidas chocaron y se
hicieron pedazos así que no fue nada
tranquilo más bien fue un proceso muy
violento que ocurrió al inicio de la
historia de la tierra así fue como se
formó la luna si avanzamos a cuando se
formó la tierra supongamos que este es
nuestro planeta y se cree que un
protoplaneta o casi planeta porque era
aproximadamente del tamaño de marte
chocó con la tierra aquí tenemos una
imagen que representa la colisión donde
el planeta de la derecha es del tamaño
de marte y chocó con el que más tarde se
convirtió en la tierra a este planeta se
le conoce como díaz y se cree que chocó
en un lado de la tierra no fue un golpe
directo porque eso habría destruido
ambos planetas provocando que se
fundieran en una sola masa pero se dice
que hubo un choque de lado como éste
entonces supongamos que esta es la
tierra y por aquí tenemos aquí a díaz se
acercó a la tierra con un cierto ángulo
y las energías combinadas por esa
interacción podrían haber provocado una
fusión aunque probablemente se fundieron
un poco porque había un montón de
pequeñas colisiones golpeando la
superficie en los dos planetas durante
todo ese tiempo pero como el choque fue
de lado eso arrojó un montón de material
fundido hacia la órbita así que primero
choca en un lado de la tierra y sale
volando un montón de material fundido
quizá un poco de ese material fue jalado
por la tierra entonces esto sería el
antes y para él después imaginemos que
la tierra es una esfera muy caliente y
algunas partes están deformadas por la
colisión
díaz que ha colisionado está fundida
si avanzamos en el tiempo todo esto que
salió volando hacia la órbita y que va
en esta dirección todo esto se convirtió
en la luna y el resto de este material
eventualmente se condensó en una esfera
y se convirtió en lo que ahora conocemos
como tierra entonces así fue como se
formó la luna y aún después de todo eso
la tierra siguió experimentando cambios
violentos y sólo para tener una idea de
la historia de la tierra veamos este
reloj geológico que empieza justo aquí
en la formación de nuestro sistema solar
hace aproximadamente 4.6 mil millones de
años y conforme nos movemos hacia la
derecha en el diagrama avanzamos en el
tiempo hasta acercarnos a la era en la
que nos encontramos y bueno solo para
que entiendan un poco la terminología
significa mil millones de años g por
giga y emea significa millones de años m
por mega entonces cuando se formó la
luna nos encontrábamos en el león jávea
no o también llamado un jade y ccoo este
es el león jadeando y un león es un
periodo de tiempo muy largo que
comprende aproximadamente mil millones
de años pero lo que hace a león jade a
no tan diferente es que desde el punto
de vista geológico no existían rocas en
este on todavía no existía lo
macroscópico y eso era porque la tierra
todavía estaba fundida sólo había magma
y lava derretida como resultado de todas
las colisiones por lo que toda la
energía cinética se convertía en calor
entonces si observáramos la superficie
de la tierra durante el león jade ano en
el que probablemente
nos gustaría estar porque nos podría
caer un meteorito o quemarnos con magma
además de que no podríamos respirar pero
veríamos algo como esto veríamos una
gran piscina de magma por eso no había
rocas porque las rocas constantemente se
derretían quedándose en el magma aunque
bueno la tierra sigue teniendo material
fundido solo que nosotros vivimos en la
capa delgada y fría la corteza pero si
analizáramos lo que existe debajo de la
corteza encontraríamos magma y si
profundizamos más encontraremos hierro
líquido entonces éste eon fue muy
violento y al final del eón hadyan o la
tierra comenzó a endurecerse pero
constantemente muchas cosas caían del
cielo chocando con la tierra uniéndose a
ella pero bueno aquí nos vamos a quedar
recuerden que hasta este punto todavía
no hay vida en la
muchas personas creen que la vida empezó
a aparecer al final de león' hadyan oh
pero en gran parte el ambiente era muy
hostil y no era tan fácil entonces nos
quedaremos aquí en el siguiente vídeo
hablaremos del eón arcaico